if you think about the key reasons for
ending this economic invisibility I'd
see them as five different reasons
firstly that the sheer size and scale of
the losses to human welfare as a result
of the loss of ecosystems and
biodiversity are two significant to
ignore anymore are we talking about
trillions of dollars of natural capital
per year being wiped out as a result of
business as usual as a result of the
pace of losses so if the society that is
making this decision is you and me like
we are fairly well-to-do people we can
afford to look after our children I will
find very difficult to justify this as
an ethical choice to my two daughters as
in that way you know I'm just traded off
your children's future at one seventh or
what it is today but if our society were
a poor community we and we don't know
where our next meal comes from then it
is important for us to be fed in order
to maintain our children never mind that
children so then we might apply the
opposite logic as in a high discount
rate to the future because what's coming
to us today from nature is worth a lot
more to our society compared to what may
come to us the same thing in 50 years
time so we would have a different
ethical perspective on that more
important to feed me and my babies now
as against worry about their children in
50 years time these are ethical choices
they're complex societal ethical choices
and we have to recognize these when we
undertake valuation and make use of
discount rates